le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
accueillir à temps complet au sein de sa
famille un enfant réunionnais en
difficulté c'est le quotidien du beau
métier d'assistante familiale
c'est un métier qui bénéficie de la
dynamique et du soutien d'une équipe de
professionnels travailleurs sociaux et
médico sociaux psychologues médecins
mais plus qu'un métier c'est aussi une
vocation faite d'amour et de dévouement
quelles sont les conditions pour être
assistante familiale
quel est son rôle exact on en parle tout
de suite dans lien social
le métier d'assistante familiale n'est
pas à confondre avec celui d'assistante
maternelle une assistante familiale a
pour rôle principal d'offrir un enfant
séparé de sa famille des conditions de
vie lui permettant de poursuivre son
développement physique psychique
affectif et sa socialisation
l'accueil prévu par la loi peut être
permanent intermittent ou d'urgence
suivant les décisions de justice avant
l'accueil d'un enfant il faut près de 60
heures de stage et suivant l'accueil du
premier enfant un délai de trois ans
dont une formation de 240 heures pour
avoir la possibilité de passer le
diplôme d'état d'assistante familiale
corinne boulanger fait partie de ceux
qui sont en cours de diplômes elle nous
livre son parcours il ya quatre ans avec
mon mari et l'accord de nos enfants
j'ai fait ma demande auprès du conseil
général pour devenir famille d'accueil
un métier que je connaissais déjà bien
puisque ma mère l'a exercé pendant 24
ans est aujourd'hui à la retraite je
suis donc devenue assistante familiale
agréé par la pmi depuis 2011 et g
travail pour le conseil général de
l'autorité de la présidente et j'ai un
statut d'agents non titulaires de la
fonction publique alors c'est un métier
que j'exerce à mon domicile et de façon
permanente
je ne travaille pas seul je fais partie
d'une équipe pluridisciplinaire et au
quotidien mon encadrement est assurée
par un référent professionnel je suis
actuellement une formation obligatoire
de près 300 heures à la rts de
saint-benoît et cette formation mène
diplôme d'état le diplôme d'assistante
familiale actuellement j'accueille deux
enfants une petite fille de 6 ans et un
petit garçon de 22 mois je suis tenu au
secret professionnel
les concernant et concernant leur
famille proche ou éloignée toutes les
décisions concernant les enfants sont
plus en accord avec les parents et de
toutes les façons les parents sont
associés à la vie de leurs enfants qui
nous sont confiées au quotidien je prend
en charge les enfants je les accompagne
dans leur scolarité dans leur éducation
dans leur socialisation je reste à leur
écoute et je mène auprès d'eux des
référents enfants toutes les
informations qui me semblent importantes
concernant ces petits formats par cette
profession demande de l'investissement
personnel de la patience et la
contribution de toute la famille mes
enfants mais beaucoup
dans le métier le fait que tout le monde
s'investisse naturellement avec amour
aide les enfants à trouver leur place au
sein de notre foyer en finale plus qu'un
métier une
vocation
vu des bienfaits que cela apporte aux
enfants et à nous mêmes
régine virassamy sakhri est ainsi sans
psaume il yal depuis près de 26 ans est
actuellement j'accueille trois enfants
une jeune fille de 15 ans un garçon de
11 ans et un autre petit de 7 ans
mais depuis ces 26 années j'en ai appuyé
pas mal
de la naissance à 21 ans pour exercer ce
métier je dirais qu'il faut
non seulement aimer les enfants mais
aussi faut avoir une capacité d'accueil
qui demande beaucoup de patience
beaucoup d'énergie parce qu'on nous
confie parfois des enfants qui sont
complètement brisé et il faut essayer de
les ramener de les reconstituer de l'est
et de les aimer parce que beaucoup
d'entre eux croient qu'ils ne sont pas
aimables il y en a pas mal qui sont
grands maintenant qu'ils sont devenus
parents et qui reviennent me voir et ça
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
j'ai eu à accueillir des enfants
malentendants donc j'ai eu la
possibilité d'apprendre la langue des
signes et sur une année entière j'ai
fait l'information pour pouvoir
communiquer avec les enfants comme
confié le métier d'assistante familiale
c'est surtout dans la prise en charge au
quotidien des enfants
donc
la première des choses qu'on leur
apprend quand ils arrivent chez nous
c'est les règles de vie dans une famille
qu'il faut dire bonjour s'il vous plaît
dire merci parce qu'il y en a beaucoup
qui ne le font pas à prendre l'enfant à
être propre sur lui même comment se
tenir parce qu'il faut aller à l'école
qu'on doit les accompagner tous les
jours tous les matins aller les chercher
tous les soirs faire les devoirs avec le
soir pour un enfant il faut l'amener à
ce qu'ils respectent les règles de vie
et pour certains c'est très difficile
parce que quand ils arrivent chez nous à
13 14 ans et qui a failli de repères du
tout il faut tout recommencer à zéro
pour devenir assistante familiale il
faut obtenir un agrément délivré par la
présidence du conseil général après une
évaluation effectuée par le service de
la protection maternelle et infantile la
paix amy posséder des qualités d'écouté
anticiper les besoins de l'enfant lui
apporter infections et un sentiment de
sécurité être disponible et discret sont
indispensables pour assurer la fonction
d'assistante familiale un beau métier
méconnu qui méritait un coup de
projecteur
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais